[Music]
so what humans do that specialist we
absorb all of these ideas all these
inputs and we smoosh them up in various
ways and come up with new things and so
there are essentially three main ways
that the brain does this and we've
summarized this as bending breaking and
blending so let's start with bending
bending is where you take something and
you you change it you make it smaller
you make it bigger you change something
about it when you look at statues across
human culture you find that that people
bend the human form any which way making
it taller or skinnier emphasizing
certain portions over the other they do
that with all animal paintings and
sculptures and so on you can bend lots
of aspects of things so the artist jr.
made a statue of the high jumper
muhammad idris for the olympics and he
put that a super-huge and had him
jumping over a building and you have
other sculptors that make extremely tiny
little figurines and one of the
arguments we make is that the exact same
thing that's happening in art the same
cognitive processes are happening in the
sciences also so you see exactly this
kind of thing happening all the time
just as an example in the early days of
driving in the 1920s headlight glare was
a real problem
so Edwin land the scientists realized
that he could solve this by using
polarizing crystals but those were very
big at the time so he figured out how to
shrink these down and make a windshield
out of all these little polarized
crystals it's exactly the same sort of
aha moment as the artist who's making
these tiny figurines it's the same kind
of bend going on and we see this all
over in in biology just as one example
the artificial heart since it was
invented in the 1980s has been a
mechanical pump but these are very
energy hungry and they get worn down and
so in 2004 a couple of physicians came
up with a continuous flow heart where
blood flows through and is oxygenated
continuously so if you have one of these
hearts you don't have a pulse it
all Dick Cheney has one of these he
doesn't have a pulse and so this is a
bend of what we find the nature we get
the idea of the heart and then we bend
it to make it compatible with what we
want and of course airplanes are are a
bend of you know what we witnessed birds
doing and so on so there are many ways
that you can bend things and this is one
of the great things that the brain does
all the time so breaking is where you
take something some input that you've
received and you bust it into pieces
maybe you leave pieces out or something
like that so just as an example the
artist Cory Arcangel took the video game
Super Mario Brothers and he hacked into
it and he removed everything except for
the little clouds and then he made an
art installation where it was just the
clouds and he called it Super Mario
clouds what he was doing was taking part
of it away leaving part of it there that
same kind of overt creativity that
happens in the arts is exactly what
happens in the scientific lab all the
time where you take certain parts away
for example in my field there's a method
that's used now in neuroscience called
clarity where you take the the brain
which you can't see inside of and you
wash away all the fatty molecules so
that you can see where the pathways
originate where they go and in that way
you can essentially make part of the
brain transparent you can suddenly see
the pathways it's the exact same idea
just as another example the artist David
Hockney takes the the visual field and
breaks it up into pieces and the
impressionist painter Seurat does
pointillism so there's there's these
sort of big dots and they're seeing
these dots if you come up close you see
them if you go far away it looks like a
painting and this exact same sort of
breaking is the innovation that
underlies our whole digital universe
because there's pixelation of everything
you see on a computer screen it's a
bunch of individual squares that have
different colors and at the right
distance you see me talking on a big
think video fred sanger was trying to
figure out how to sequence long
molecules of DNA and he realized that he
could break these up into smaller pieces
and then you can
analyze and collate the information he
actually ended up winning two Nobel
prizes for this work that he did and
it's the basis of essentially everything
we know about genomes at this point but
it's all the same cognitive operations
that are happening that you see both in
the art and in the sciences what happens
in the arts is overt bending breaking
and blending so you see all kinds of art
projects where people are taking things
in they're bending them and in size or
texture or they're breaking them they're
breaking pieces off or they're blending
two ideas this is the basis of all the
art that we see exactly the same
mechanisms are happening in the
scientific lab it's just that typically
we can't see them so when you pick up
your cell phone it's this little
rectangle that is absolutely chock-full
of creativity of really brilliant ideas
that went into the making of that but
you can't see it because it's just a
little you know enclosed thing but the
interesting part is it's it's exactly
the same cognitive mechanisms which is
to say absorbing the world bending
breaking and blending it and spitting
out new versions of things one of the
things that we love about our computers
is that we can put information in there
and then when we pull it out a year
later it's exactly the same it's exactly
the same zeros and ones
the human brain doesn't work that way
when you put stuff in it gets smooshed
up with other things that have come in
before and what comes out are you know
new versions of things so blending is
where you have two completely separate
ideas and then these become blended in
the brain and something new comes out so
just as an example in ancient mythology
we see this all throughout where you
have for example a man the lion and and
you get a sphinx or you get all over the
world different combinations a lion and
a goat you get a chimera exactly the
same thing happens in the lab just as
one example scientists have long wanted
to harvest spider silk which is actually
stronger than steel for its size but you
can't get a bunch of spiders together or
they'll eat each other so what a
geneticist did is he spliced out the
gene that makes spider silk and put it
in a
and made freckles the spider goat who
secretes spider silk in her milk she's a
real-life chimera and this idea of
taking two separate things and blending
them is something that humans do all the
time we take very different concepts and
we put them together
[Music]